[Musique]
Michel coje Marie Vastel Christian
Dufour bonsoir
vous allez me dire certains d'entre vous
Michel et Christian notamment on en a
beaucoup parlé un peu moins avec Marie
mais quand même le troisième lien on
l'avait dit c'était écrit dans le ciel
etc non pêche n'empêche c'est une
volte-face spectaculaire
et là tout le monde se positionne face à
ça je vais avant de vous laisser la
parole vous faire réentendre monsieur
Legault et les oppositions et on revient
tout de suite
une décision difficile mais il faut
comprendre que la situation beaucoup
changé vous allez le voir demain dans
les données
les impacts du télétravail
sont énormes on pensait que ça ça
reviendrait comme avant la pandémie
après la fin de la pandémie donc
vraiment il y a un changement important
faut s'adapter à l'évolution de ce
changement là
ça fait cinq ans ça fait cinq ans que
François Legault niaise les gens de
Québec ça fait 5 ans que l'enjeu de
mobilité a été constaté sous le gouverne
du gouvernement logo justement et qu'il
n'y a rien fait c'est une victoire du
gros bon sens et de la science
puis une défaite de l'entêtement
caquiste sur ce projet qui était depuis
le départ
injustifié quelles sont les chances que
la CAQ était sincère pensait sincèrement
faire son troisième lien en version
autour routine lorsqu'elle faisait
campagne qu'elle disait qu'elle avait
des études puis qu'elle est révélerait
éventuellement
c'est effectivement la question qui se
pose est-ce que lors de la campagne la
dernière campagne électorale où il a été
beaucoup question de troisième bien
Christian Dufour je commence avec vous
est-ce que on savait dans les officines
du gouvernement dans les stratèges
kakises que ça allait pas pouvoir se
faire vraiment ou pas Christian
m'étonnerait que on savait qu'on
s'apprête pas se faire quand les
premiers moi je trouve pas que les
politiciens sont machiavéliques à ce
point là mais mes choses certaines c'est
un dossier énorme à Québec ça a été le
gros engagement de la CAQ à Québec et ça
va leur faire très mal dans la région
Québec vous interviewez tout à l'heure
iridiens c'est un beau cadeau iridien me
dit a voulu faire plaisir aux
chroniqueurs de Montréal je pose
électeur de Québec donc une espèce de
perte de confiance à l'égard de la CAQ
dans la grande région de Québec je le
dis moi je suis un peu bizarrement par
rapport à ce dossier là parce que la
gestion de monsieur Legault se défend
quelque à Paris prouve aussi qui est
capable de bouger monsieur Legault
c'est une plus forte il peut bouger puis
là le nouveau projet est-ce qu'il va se
réaliser ou c'est une autre étape vers
la fin je le sais pas mais en plus de
chances qui se réalise parce que plus de
chance qu'on a un financement fédéral
bon il est plus consensuel même s'il va
avoir beaucoup de position puis
d'insatisfaits aussi tant qu'à prendre
une décision comme ça autant la prendre
au début du mandat parce que je le
répète quand même à Québec c'était une
grosse affaire-là Marie vacelle
Christian vient de le dire le projet qui
sera proposé demain c'est un tunnel mais
avec uniquement du transport collectif
ce qui fait et c'est un c'est pas un
détail qu'il pourra être financé en
partie importante par Ottawa
oui je vous dirais qu'à atao aujourd'hui
on s'est retenu quand même parce qu'on
ne fait pas avoir l'air baveux
excusez-moi expression face à la CAQ
mais on sentait quand même
qu'on était un peu satisfait du
revirement de situation dans le sens où
on vient un peu confirmer ce que le
fédéral disait que il y a pas
nécessairement un tel besoin compte tenu
de la chalandage que la qualité de l'air
à Québec n'est pas bonne excès n'était
pas une bonne idée d'ajouter un
autoroute automobile et quand j'ai
croisé Dominique Leblanc ministre des
Affaires intergouvernementales et de
l'infrastructure au Parlement ce midi il
a reconnu effectivement que le projet
s'il ressemble à ce qu'on nous laisse
entendre
aurait beaucoup de chance de se
qualifier pour un fond fédéral dédié aux
infrastructures de transport en commun
mais on est prudent on dit qu'on veut
d'abord voir le projet les détails les
évaluations environnementales parce
qu'on note sourire en coin que le projet
a changé de forme plusieurs fois depuis
plusieurs années donc ce n'est pas un
oui garanti tout de suite mais on
comprend qu'il y a pas mal de chances
que le projet se qualifie et que donc
Québec puisse avoir droit à peut-être 40
% de financement fédéral c'est quand
même un gros gros changement par rapport
au libéraux fédéraux qui disait pas
question pas besoin de ce projet-là nos
fonds de nos fonds ne servent pas à
financer des autoroutes c'est énorme
comme des taxes
à moitié de la facture Michel C vous
impressions sur cette volte-face
le mauvais côté c'est que on n'est pas
plus avancé sur la question des coûts et
le vrai problème de cette histoire-là
c'est les coûts
comme comme projet et là on faisait deux
tubes on va faire rien que ça veut pas
dire que ça coûtait 50 % moins cher on
va continuer de creuser dans son c'est
pas quoi c'est pas si du rock
à quel profondeur quels sont les mesures
d'urgence ça s'appelle etc et bien
possible que ça coûte encore très très
cher le tunnel et d'autre part il y a
deux joueurs il y a deux rives à Québec
qui sont très contents allez-y le mal de
oui et pas content du tout qu'est-ce
qu'on fait là-bas ou le transport en
commun et ordinaire pour dire le moins
est-ce qu'on laisse les gens sur lequel
la station les vies pour démarrer vous
maintenant
il va falloir avoir un système de
transport en commun allez vite ça c'est
pas fait répondre à la culture de
l'entreprise que la Ville de Lévis alors
c'est loin d'être fait
exactement c'est loin d'être fait ce
nouveau projet et à la limite il sera
moins il sera moins il constituera moins
une grande promesse électorale comme la
vérité le troisième bien mais je vous
faire entendre je vous donne la parole
après Christian monsieur Dumont qu'on a
entendu plutôt mais ce qui était pas
avec nous quand vous dites les gens sur
la Rive-Sud sont déçus écoutez le préfet
de la MRC il dit nous on avait dit qu'on
allait là on y va plus on écoute
il a été élu avec le troisième lien puis
il nous dit tout le temps quand c'est
vous peut-être on va vous le faire le
troisième bien on arrive avec ça une
plaque en pleine face
cet ordinaire c'est très ordinaire la
confiance envers le gouvernement elle
vient de tomber bas en joie le verre on
n'est pas des câbles non plus c'est pas
parce qu'on arrive Sud pour être
améliorer un peu plus brillant que les
autres c'est comme ça que vous vous
sentez ben c'est un peu ça je me sens je
me sens un peu ridiculisé d'avoir
travaillé sur le dossier
pour lui mais on voit plus d'hommes on
fait pas d'omelettes d'ailleurs on est
très généreux dans notre titre parce
qu'on dit une promesse brisée point
d'interrogation c'est une promesse
brisée monsieur Legault le reconnaît
lui-même tu sais il a fait débat des
chefs campagnes et tout le travail là
dessus pardon
trois élections là dessus trois
élections je vais vous faire entendre
parce que ça va vous rappeler des
souvenirs Michel C et Christian et Marie
chiracaps qui avait démissionné parce
que dans la campagne électorale et
libéraux avait promis d'éliminer l'ATPL
si la COP ça veut dire moi je vais
mettre mon siège en jeu tout ça puis
elle a démissionné voyant que les
libéraux n'allaient pas abolir la TPS
ils l'ont changé un petit peu c'est tout
ericare que je vous fais entendre je
vous fais entendre un extrait radio qui
leur donnait à une radio de Québec le FM
93 écoutez bien
je peux prendre un engagement
aujourd'hui là je vous le dis là qui
enregistrait le si la carte forme un
gouvernement et que j'ai quelque chose à
voir dans la réalisation de ce de ce
projet-là et qu'elle a qu'à qui ne le
fait pas je vais démissionner
je sais
démissionné avait regagné
ok Marie c'est parce que ces écrans
surtout quand
enregistrer moi et refaites le passé si
jamais ça n'arrive pas ben
malheureusement voilà mais je vais pas
être cynique mais depuis monsieur care
pas depuis mais monsieur carré
maintenant ministre des fois c'est un
petit peu plus difficile de renoncer à
ça et et sur ce que Christian disait
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que ce
revirement de situation
pourrait aider iriduel mais je ne suis
pas certaine qu'à campagne électorale
irréductuelle puisse davantage promettre
de faire un troisième lien en tout cas à
l'heure actuelle où il est dans les
sondages donc oui ça crée un gros
malaise au caucus de la CAQ oui il y a
des gens comme américains qui sont pas
très contents aujourd'hui mais dans
trois ans quand il y a une élection
je ne sais pas concrètement si ça va
vraiment avoir de gros gros impacts vu
l'autre option qui s'offre à ces
électeurs ok donc Christian la morale
c'est qu'il ne faut plus jamais qu'un
élu dit je mets mon siège en jeu où je
vais démissionner si telle chose arrive
pas à Christian
c'est vrai il faut jamais faire ces
déclarations quand on sent politique
mais moi je dirais démissionner et quand
même l'honneur personnel qui est à ce
qui se représente il peut être élu
mais l'imputabilité la responsabilité je
suis d'accord c'est que Monsieur le goût
d'ailleurs dans les problèmes de la SAC
quand je dis le boss la sac il faut que
l'imputabilité il faut que la
responsabilité ministérielle moi je
trouve que si les missionnaires ils
prendrai le blanc sur lui en disant oui
je l'ai dit parce que ça va s'extrait là
ça va jouer puis il va avoir l'air fou
hyper quand même beaucoup de crédibilité
mais quel naïveté c'est présenté demain
tout le projet du nouveau troisième bien
uniquement pour le par rapport en commun
on va avoir on aura la ministre guilbo
en entrevue avec nous demain etc je veux
rapidement vous parler de deux sujets
très rapidement en partant grève des
fonctionnaires
jouera un fil de dérivée des conclusions
mais Marie est-ce que d'après vous ce
que vous sentez ça en ligne vers un
règlement rapide ou ça risque d'être
long et donc les citoyens vont empathie
je ne suis pas certaine que ce soit très
très long de 1 sur la question du
télétravail vous en avez beaucoup parlé
avec les syndicats avec la ministre
Fortier je ne suis pas certaine que le
syndicat énormément de sympathie des
citoyens sur la question du télétravail
cette question d'inscrire le droit dans
la convention collective ce qui pourrait
un peu
menotter les gestionnaires après
lorsqu'il voudrait que les employés
rentrent au travail
certains nombre de fois par semaine et
donc soit le syndicat accepte et on
s'entend à la table de négociation ou
sinon j'ai pas senti une énorme patience
de la part de Justin Trudeau matin quand
je lui ai posé la question monsieur
Trudeau qui disait mais sincèrement ce
que je dis là je pense pas que les
Canadiens vont être extrêmement patients
on croit comprendre les pas question de
loi de retour au travail ça faisait même
pas 24 heures quand on a Monsieur
Trudeau rencontré la presse et tous les
ministres ne voulaient pas parler de loi
de retour au travail mais je n'exclierai
pas que ça arrive si ça se prononce le
gouvernement vient de se débarrasser
derrière énormément dans la gestion des
passeports et autres dossiers pas sûr
qu'ils ont envie de recommencer tout ça
avec une grève des fonctionnaires la
ministre qui disait je pense que c'est
58000 demandes de passeport par semaine
qui s'accumulerait s'il y a beaucoup
s'il y a une grève et donc monsieur
Trudeau qui avait fait une noix de
retour au travail en 2018 quand il y a
une grève tournante chez post-canada
pendant un mois pas impossible qu'il
fasse la même chose si ça s'éternise
Christian
oui
avec le chef syndical je suis demandé
pourquoi ils sont engrais le droit de
faire la grève mais c'est quand même une
mesure extrêmement radicale ça fait 32
ans que pour y parce que tout a l'air
d'aller assez bien ils sont pas si loin
que ça dans les négociations donc je me
demande si le syndicat ne veut pas un
peu forcer son avantage parce que
l'autre avantage qu'il a c'est que le
gouvernement s'il y a d'autres qui nous
spéciale puis on a pas d'autres choix
d'adopter des spéciales ça se mélange
trop il va être obligé de s'appuyer ses
conservateurs aussi ça va être un peu
humiliant parce que je voudrais les
relations sont d'amour sont pas tendres
et conservateurs donc pourquoi il grève
moi je comprends pas trop ok Michel
c'est conclusion
il va probablement y avoir une noix de
retour au travail ce serait pas auteur
d'ici trois ou quatre jours mais la
syndicat le sait aussi alors
[Musique]
que leur avantage est peut-être de tenir
la grève une journée ou deux encore mais
pas de dépasser ça parce que la loi
spéciale va être automatiquement je
voulais absolument vous parler de
l'augmentation de salaire des députés on
va en parler soit demain soit notre jour
je vous promets parce que c'est
intéressant il y a un comité d'anciens
élus qui recommande d'augmenter le
salaire assez considérablement des
députés et donc des ministres à Québec
on en reparle merci beaucoup à vous
trois bonnes soirées à très bientôt au
revoir au revoir au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]